receiving this honorary Oscar tonight
and what does it mean for you at this in
this season of your life to get this
honor season last week in December
okay that's what the kids calling you
yeah you're scraping the ice off the
window
s oh he's like it's nice it's really
nice here uh all um I mean much for uh
important things
around this and then me or my career I
mean it's he's recognizing that that
this community can gather forces and get
into and attack problems societal
problems and make a difference and
that's the core of it not me but for me
it's cool
anyway you want to give it to me
kids think it's cool your kids are
notoriously hard to please dad and mom
aren't always that cool until they are
do the kids think it's cool that you're
getting the Oscar have they picked out
where it's going to go in the house
no I don't think they've ever not
thought we were cool
no but they they're they're really
excited about this I think that it has
so much meaning because of what the work
that Michael's done and and they also
have done a lot of work and I've done a
lot of work with the foundation so it
just feels like a very special way to
celebrate that and also to bring more
attention to the Parkinson's community
and the work that still needs to be
yeah is there is there a movie or a film
or project of yours that I'm sure there
are lots of lots of them have a very
special place in your heart but is there
one that holds an extra special place
and I have to say yeah two things one
thing that television family time it's
supposed to be a good night Tracy and um
and uh Back to the Future which is just
that's once in a lifetime Back to the
Future oh yeah that was a good one
like being a flying monkey is like being
part of a yeah I'm a big Hollywood
tradition
[Music]
foreign